roland dumas bonsoir merci les verts
urbains c'est la première fois que vous
venez
c'est la première fois et vous votre
fils vient quand même non oui oui après
c'est normal la nouvelle génération est
plus apte à venir chez vous donc que la
mienne maintenant tombé pour elle c'est
nobert lui disant que vous aussi vous
venez au bain exactement mais oui je
pense qu'il le verra vous connaissez
yvette horner
oui bien sûr j'admire beaucoup sans
talent je vous présente jim jones qui
est une découverte de prins et qui va
faire très très fort dans les années qui
viennent
valentina vargas qui jouait dans au nom
de la rose et d'antoine d'alfredo arias
qui s'appelle fuegos une charmante
surviennent on parle très bien le
français
j'ai visité quatre adjectifs qui vous
sont généralement attribuées et vous
allez me dire si oui ou non ils vous
conviennent alors attention premier
adjectif dilettante
oui ou non vous faites beaucoup de
choses je les tic mais ça dépend aussi
de vente ont défini de
le discours des étangs qu'est ce que
vous entendez par là ce que ça veut dire
avoir plusieurs activités plusieurs
centres d'intérêt ou en train de
s'intéresser à rien toucher à toute
façon superficielle
vous avez l'air de travailler sont
vraiment donné on avait passé près
deuxième objectif affectif machiavélique
ming au machiavélique répondait à une
phrase si c'est pour être aussi
intelligent que l'on est et machiavel
surtout dans les dom et vous évoquiez
après tout c'est pas péjoratif magic
laisser devenu péjoratif d'accord monde
un prêt oui non non j'aime bien dans le
monde mais pas tellement
voyez je suis jamais venu chez vous
pourtant c'est l'endroit à la mode est
un adjectif les derniers le bon angle le
dernier arrivé
oui et non c'est plus de mon temps
c'était de mon âge je l'étais quand
j'étais plus jeune sans doute et
d'ailleurs je savais que joue là les
vergès a dit vous qu'il comprenait mal
comment l époque louviers dans un
gouvernement aussi philosémite
vous êtes ami avec verve et nous nous
sommes beaucoup vus
nous avons plaidé beaucoup d'affaires
ensemble notamment moment de la guerre
d'algérie vergès a défendu barbie est ce
que vous défendriez le pen si vous en
tant qu'avocat vous savez le propre de
cette profession et que l'on peut
choisir choisir appris que l'on puisse
refuser pour des raisons
multiples ne serait ce que parce qu'on
estime que ce ne serait pas la hauteur
de la tâche qu'on vous confie ou la
cause que l'on vous demande de défendre
alors pour un tas de considérations je
pense que c'est une cause que je
n'accepterais pas du reste il me le
demandez pas yvette horner qu'est ce que
vous pensez de roland dumas ou pensé qu'
il est très habile comme on l'est
généralement oui je tombe en effet je
connais je suis un tout petit peu la
politique c'est un homme extraordinaire
un homme exceptionnel et
je pense que mademoiselle tout à l'heure
que vous lui demandez un tas d'autres
précisions bien sûr on sait très bien
qu'il ya une diplomatie on peut pas
répondre comme ça il faut quand même
réfléchir c'est le propre de la
politique de réfléchir est ce que vous
trouvez beau parce qu'il a une
réputation de playboy il vous plait moi
je dois du fait de redpath non je trouve
que cela passe pas je te fait l'étalagé
quand on fait un défi qu'il est très bon
je trouvais très beau oui et vous
wedding enfin je retournerais hansson
hans hoffman et toi il est pas mal à la
tête je me trouve aussi charmant une
fête une fête unanimité mais c'est sont
défendus dans l'emploi dans la
diplomatie alors je ne sais pas si je
dois y ajouter foi est ce que vous
pensez que votre physique vous à aider
dans vos missions vous de sourire
votants cheveux argentés vos yeux bleus
à écouter
il ya des cas où je ne souris pas vous
seriez très bien vengé pas toujours eu
les cheveux argentés et puis parce que
les paysans c'est pour départager les
diables fait voilà cette fois la
confiance
on voulait voir mais aussi d'autres
d'autres éléments quoi vous vous
souvenez ton accordéon me fatigue est si
tu jouais plutôt de la clarinette et
maintenant c'est ça n'a rien changé du
monde d'accordéon
maintenant c'est gautier qui fait vos
clips alors quel effet ça fait d'être
devenu
une star débrancher après avoir été
critiqué il ya 20 ans par par antoine
c'est à dire que critiquer critiquer
citer d'autres géants ça va non ça m'a
donné un tout petit peu mais enfin vous
savez c'est parti mon dieu la critique
il faut la prendre il faut la lire il
faut la laisser de côté il faut en
prendre soin non sécurisation jour là
antoine j'ai pu la lui un bien c est ce
qu on pourrait dire oui voyage et je
pourrai dire que j'ai quand même
continué et de l'accordéon a toujours
marché
alors quand vous étiez petit voulais
être concertiste épicé vos parents qui
vous ont dit finalement tu devrais jouer
de l'accordéon parce que l'accordéon
quand même dont on meurt pas de faim
quand on joue de l'accordéon là est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous donneriez la moitié
de votre carrière d'accordéonistes pour
une carrière de concertiste
non je referais la même chose vous
referiez la même si seulement la même
chose c'est à dire que quand mes parents
m'ont demandé de laisser les études
classiques de continuer après le
conservatoire d'apprendre la porno mais
sûr j'ai pleuré pendant trois ans on
peut dire trois ans je pouvais visite
impossible d'entendre une notes de piano
à la radio car j'ai eu c'était un
effondrement
j'avais perdu un amour un amour très
cher et qui n'a jamais que mourir
d'ailleurs qui est toujours dans mon
coeur c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
enregistré un disque là mais justement
parlons-en oui vous aurez indice de
classe et bien un disque classique au
piano avec deux listes de granados
albeniz
des études de l'iss et à la corde héros
dans l'autre face il ya des 506
scarlatti
ducasse qui lie à vue d'atteindre enfin
c'est pareil quand on est habile de ses
doigts on veut jouer de l'accordéon on
peut jouer du piano mais t'as pas bilou
à dire ça demande un travail intense
c'est une discipline que l'on doit
s'imposer une discipline je dirais
réduite à 50 60 % quand on est en amour
quand on fait les choses avec passion
avec amour
donc c'est un travail constant est ce
que j'ai dit moi je travaille beaucoup
mais c'est vrai ce que je viens de sidi
hmad site sans travail c'est une légende
et moi je connais les plus grands
travail mais ils donnent pas toujours
l'impression d'être arras et je vais te
coucher à 6 heures du matin j'ai fait
600 km vous êtes là s'il avoue sortait
un livre c'est finalement sur ma
carrière c'est pas chez carla font
format se disant que l'on me demande et
c'est pas chez carrère non annoncés chez
filipacchi oui c'est tellement de
travail intense donc
silva et la musique il ya une chose que
se passait il faut se remettre en
question tous les jours
tous les jours on ne sait jamais vous
avez le trac quand vous montez sur une
scène vous êtes toujours le trac
j'essaie de devait être cette trempe là
parce que si vous voulez si on me
demande de compter jusqu'à 2100 mhz
arrêté et c'est une image sur scène je
compterai jusqu'à 100000 ouais voilà
alors donc le reste il faut jouer
toujours beaucoup plus fortes
contraintes que l'on exécute en public
et ça je pensais que un peu on peut
maîtriser faut maîtriser bien sûr
l'instrument et sa demande toute une vie
et qu'est ce vous faites contre le trac
quand vous avez un peu le trac vous
faites quoi
j'ai mangé une soupe de champagne non
non non surtout pas surtout pas ça veut
pas alors je me posais une question qui
nous brûle les lèvres c'est que vous
avez joué dans une fête organisée par
couscous clan actuelle à la cartoucherie
avec mort et mory kante
est ce que c'est une prise de position
politique est-ce que vous est ce que
c'est une prise de position finalement
en faveur du mélange d
mesure vous savez clé les musiciens
donne de l'amour
beaucoup d'amour on ne verrait pas un
musicien prendre vouloir tirer derrière
un temps canon honneur c'est la poésie
c'est un travail bien sûr j'ai dû tout à
l'heure et lorsqu'on m'a proposé de
faire cette émission à la cartoucherie
de vincennes avec des moniteurs couleur
mory kante avec l'arabe et cetera c'est
une idée qui m'a séduite par ce que je
pense moi bien sûr
le musicien est là pour dire que l'on
peut s'attendre à y a pas que le vix
s'est bien passé nos vins le logiciel
est là pour tendre pour tendre la main
pour donner de dalida boréale
heureusement fait ces soirées là et nous
vivons policiers ont pas alors étant
donné que celui qui jouit de l'arpp
indienne me dit je ne peux pas
enregistrés en
je ne veux pas jouer dans plusieurs tons
je le peux je vais terminer molle
j'avais beaucoup tes lorsque ce sera à
vous de vous exprimer je ferai passer
mon orchestre en mi bémol tout le monde
durant idées molles et vous pourrez vous
étiez très bonne et nous avons aujourd
hui alors finalement ça a été une
improvisation
pendant les quatre heures de temps et
j'ai passé une soirée
je peux dire qu'il marquera dans ma
carrière nous avons joué avec beaucoup
d'amour
nous sommes relégués nous sommes tendu
la main c'est quelque chose qui passe
est absolument
roland dumas ça devrait vous faire
plaisir ça 2g de voir yvette horner
aller jouer avec mory kante avec des
musiciens africains
rave très beau je trouve pas de pain
tellement bien de la musique et danse
joue très bien mais c'est ma vie parce
qu'il va donner un duel tricolore
si on pouvait parler delà de la
politique la même façon et celle qui
colore segment binaire pour dire que ses
jours lundi qu'ils avaient un nom
mitterrand est venu après
avec [ __ ] landes et qui ont trouvé cette
soirée disons
je m'excuse et moi on m'a fait
exceptionnel puisque c'était le désir
d'en faire une des grands soirs et au
mois d'octobre très bien avec plusieurs
assauts tendront la main on pour le
faire voir au monde que c'est l'amour
qu'il faut c'est d'amour
ces chaleurs chaleur humaine et est
importante on ne peut pas vivre son
amour on peut pas vivre son âge et y ait
voulu 1500 septembre et ça n'existe pas
c'est fondamental et j'étais très
heureux c'était je vous dise
j'ai été séduite par cette idée et je
leur serai avec un grand plaisir et vous
avez été élevé chez les bonnes soeurs
est ce que vous êtes toujours croyant
citoyens se traduit comment vous faites
une prière à leur entrée sur scène non
non ce sera dit oui comment on n'a pas
besoin de fréquenter l'église a fait un
bond c'est moi qui le pense je fais
peut-être une erreur mais on peut très
bien être pouvoir croyant on peut prier
partout non je fais pas de frais hier
une rentrée mais je suis croyant je ne
suis pas pratiquante et parce que le
temps mais n'empêche
mais il ya une forme si vous voulez des
pratiques dans la croyance
donc je pense que je n'ai peut-être pas
besoin d'aller à l'église tous les to
lead in roland dumas vous êtes croyant
je crois que l'existence de la divinité
ou à l'ordre des choses à l'ordre du
monde
oui je ne suis pas je suis pas forcément
engagée dans une religion
et je pense aussi qu'il ya un tronc
commun toutes les religions oui je suis
cette forme dont parle c'est bien fait
c'est à dire la richesse l'humanité
voilà ça change il n'y a pas plusieurs
guéguen after et plusieurs façons ils
arrivaient y en a qu'un là cette
divinité unis des divinités qui bien sûr
je pense qu on ne peut pas dire voilà
c'est mon dieu je suis la police est ce
que ceux ci seront effacés
non il ya un seul dieu merci interpréter
le comme vous voudrez je suis ravi de
vous entendre dire les choses si
importante dans un endroit où on sait
mieux c'est merci beaucoup d'endroit sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus